in our eye on earth series we're taking
a look ahead to a landmark United
Nations climate action summit scheduled
for next week CBS News is the only
broadcast network participating in the
covering climate now project in
partnership with 250 other news outlets
we are highlighting the health of our
planet with our own original reporting
we like to do that today we're taking
you deep under the Florida Keys to the
only undersea science lab in the world
where marine biologists can live for
weeks at a time Mark Phillips strapped
on his scuba gear to show us what
they're learning good morning from about
four miles off the Florida Keys often
the hardest part of a story is getting
to it this one is only 50 feet away the
problem is it's straight down about five
miles off Isla Murata in the Florida
Keys is an underwater lab called the
Aquarius reef base and this is the only
way to get to it the lab sits those 50
feet down on the ocean floor and has
only recently come back into service
after being knocked out of commission by
Hurricane Emma two years ago the storm
damaged the surface unit that provides
power and pumps air down to the lab and
enough pressure to keep that air in and
the water out inside you swim into what
they call the wet porch for good reasons
it's got all the comforts of home if
you're a fish a world where the onboard
electronics could interfere with TV
pictures marine scientist Jim for Qin
spends a lot of time down here as part
of the Florida International University
team that runs the place once you're in
it it feels like an underwater RV with
the difference a lot of attention is
paid to make sure that oxygen
concentrations are correct and the co2
is at the right level and the
temperature and humidity and all the
stuff is yet you can forget your 50 odd
feet below the surface yeah you really
can if you don't look out the window the
point of being down here is that
actually living on the sea floor means
scientists can do more than just the
relatively short dives that are possible
from the surface once it climatized to
the pressure they can stay out for hours
and down here for days they almost
become says marine ecologist mike Hyde
House sea creatures themselves you can
be the ocean down here well you really
can be the ocean so you get a sense of
change that you don't with just
instruments of the water or just little
tiny dime so you need these
observatories like Aquarius to keep an
eye on what the reefs are doing and
figure out their solutions
here's one of the major problems the
Aquarius scientists are working on
hurricane Irma also did major damage to
the seagrass beds that grow just off the
coast why does that matter
think greenhouse gases and global
warming there's as much co2 stored in
seagrass Meadows as there is in tropical
forests on an acre by acre basis so an
acre of the Amazon rainforest compared
to an acre of seagrass can they have
about to mount Carmen store which is
which is a good thing it is good thing
and we're losing sea grasses faster than
we're losing for a reasonable not only
that because turtles eat seagrass and
there are fewer sharks around to eat
Turtles the grass never gets a chance to
grow back
turtles are watching what's going on
around them and if everybody gets eaten
there you're not going to do what
everybody was doing so just having
sharks in the area of what you said
controls the number of turtles that are
eating it's the kind of observation that
takes the time only a place like
Aquarius can provide more and more the
world's oceans and what they mean from
greenhouse gases and so for global
warming is becoming a crucial part of
climate science and that study has made
a whole lot easier
Mary nights I was wondering are they
going to cut to that other shot go Marc
Villa mera Club can I say it's very
clever of mr. Phillips to use the
environmental beat the london-based mr.
Phillips
keep giving assignments that involve
swimming in Florida nicely done never
gets tanner but he said you could forget
you're underwater until you look outside
the shark swims by